ليس هذا هو أسعد عودة للوطن ، فقد
كانت بلدة هجين بالقرب من نهر الفرات
في شرق سوريا
مسرحًا لقصف مكثف للتحالف
تلاه قتال من منزل إلى منزل
بين
داعش والقوات الكردية المدعومة من قبلنا ،
إنه تكرار لنفس السيناريو
الذي هو  لعبت
من الموصل إلى الرقة والآن ها
هو الموقف الأخير لداعش لإنقاذ البلدات
والمدن من المتطرفين يجب
تدميرهم ،
عادت الزهراء مع أسرتها
قبل يومين وتبيع الوجبات الخفيفة لكسب بعض المال ،
ابنتها الصغيرة لم
تدرك
ما حدث  بدأ بعض
سكان هذه البلدة التي تم تحريرها من تنظيم الدولة
في كانون الأول / ديسمبر بالعودة ،
ولكنهم عادوا إلى ما
تعرضت له معظم المباني إما لأضرار بالغة أو دمرت تمامًا ،
لذا فإن أفضل ما يمكنهم فعله في
هذه المرحلة
هو مجرد استعادة ممتلكاتهم
ومن ثم  غادر مرة أخرى
الأسبوع الماضي ليجد منزله في حالة خراب ولا
توجد طريقة لإعالة أسرة هنا
ولا توجد علامة على أن أي حكومة أو
سلطة أخرى  بدأت في إزالة
الأنقاض واستعادة ما يشبه الحياة الطبيعية ،
وقد استمرت هذه الحرب
بتركيز أحادي على
هزيمة العدو مع القليل من الاهتمام
لما
يحدث في اليوم التالي لإعلان النصر.